meanwhile President Vladimir zielinski
has appeared to confirm that Russian
forces are in control of Bahamut in
eastern Ukraine the head of the Wagner
mercenary group released a video showing
what he says is his forces in control of
the city Ukraine's government strongly
refuted the report though and when asked
directly president zlinski gave this
response
I think no
but you have to to understand that there
is nothing they destroyed everything
there are no buildings it's a Pity it's
tragedy but for today
is only in our hearts there is nothing
on this place so just drowned and
and
a lot of dead Russians but they came to
us
Let's cross over to Keith now speak to
our correspondent Natasha Butler who's
standing by Natasha obviously you just
heard president zielinski talk about the
fact that bakmut is in his hearts and in
his country's Hearts difficult to know
really how to gauge what Kiev wants to
say about bakludes right now
well look president zielinski saying
that Vaca Motors is still in our hearts
that there is nothing left there he does
seem to be conceding uh that Ukraine has
lost this uh Eastern uh city that has
been so bitterly fought over for the
past 10 months now of course his
comments do come just a day after uh
Ukrainian military officials and
government officials here in Kiev denied
those reports by uh the boss of Wagner
saying that wagon and Russian forces
were now in control of the city so it is
a bit of a mixed picture but I think
when we hear president zielinski there
he does seem to be conceding that
Ukraine may have lost uh Bak mutton if
so that would be a terrible loss a very
sad day for Ukraine this city symbolizes
so much for people here really has
become a symbol of Ukrainian resistance
of resilience so many Ukrainian lives
have been lost after fighting that wall
and so many people across the country
touched and following what has been
happening in Bachman all this time and
there are some who say look he should
have perhaps withdrawn its forces some
months ago in order to save some lives
others who say that Keith decided to
remain in bakmut and defend it in order
to try and force Russia to focus and
commit its forces there whilst Kiev
prepares a counter-offensive and of
course if we sort of focus now to where
president zielinski is over in Hiroshima
and his visit to the G7 members I mean
what sort of traction is this getting
back home across Ukraine because also
there's this major announcement isn't
there about sort of fighter the F-16
fighter jet availability as well
well look everyone's following uh
Vladimir zielinski's visit to Japan very
closely indeed watching those meetings
with G7 leaders looking at those
announcements lenski's been on this huge
diplomatic push ahead of this
anticipated Ukrainian counter-offensive
to try and Shore out more support and
more weapons and now of course we have
the United States giving its green light
to Ukraine's allies to be able to
deliver their F-16 us-made uh Jets to
Ukraine should they want to do so that
is something that zielinski has been
asking for for many many months now so
it is a big step there's lots of talk
about it being a game changer but look
there are real challenges as well
because it will take time to deliver
those Jets you have to train the pilots
there are weapons that will be needed
for those Jets as well and then this
whole uh situation in which of course
Kiev is not supposed to escalate this
conflict any further something that
Western powers are are very watching
very very closely indeed in a vast
repeatedly Ukraine will give you these
weapons but they mustn't be seen as
escalating this conflict with Russia any
further for the update thanks very much
Natasha Butler for us there in Kiev